وصفها بالمحطه الفاشله التي تبث اخبارا
زائفه تعارك مع مراسليها اكثر من مره
ووضعها في قائمه ما اسماه بالاعلام
المعادي او عدو الشعب
لكن الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب يبدو بانه
قد غير من ارائه وفتح صفحه تصالح مع قناه
سي ان حيث قبل ان يجري حوارا مع المحطه
الاسبوع القادم في ولايه نيوهامشر ويتلقى
اسئله من الناخبين على شكل تجمع يسمى تاون
هول
ليس من المستغرب ان يجري الرئيس السابق
ترامب مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان يحب
الدعايه ويحب سجلات مع الاشخاص الذين
يختلف معهم ايضا تم اجراء مقابلات مع
اثنين من المرشحين الجمهوريين الاخرين
لمنصب الرئيس ماسي ان ان
الرئيس السابق يدرك تماما انه لا يستطيع
الفوز بحوالي 30% من الاصوات وهي القاعده
المخلصه له فعليه ان يوسع من دائرته
الضيقه لذا فاللجوء الى الاعلام غير
المتعاطف معه سيعطيه فرصه للحديث مباشره
مع الناخبين المستقلين في السابق كان
الرئيس ترامب يلجا الى قناه المفضله وهي
قناه فوكس لكنه الان يدرك حجم المعركه
الانتخابيه القادمه وخصوصا وان خصمه
المتوقع حاكم ولايه فلوريدا راند سانتوس
ينمى بنفسه عن اجراء مقابلات تلفزيونيه
ولا يزال ترم يتقدم بعشرين نقطه على حاكم
فلوريدا روند سانتس لكن هذا قد يتغير
سريعا عندما يعلن الاخير ترشحه رسميا
يبقى ان نرى ما الذي سيفعله ديسانس مع
اقتراب الاستحقاق الرئاسي وما اذا كان
سيعلن عن ترشحه لكنك محقه تماما كان خجولا
حقا في مقابلته الاعلاميه الرئيسيه
وعلى غير العاده قررت رمل دعوه مجموعه من
المراسلين للسفر على متن طائراته الخاصه
خطوه تظهر دور الاعلام النافذ في
الانتخابات القادمه
العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات